we have been talking now for over a week
about the possible
unintended or maybe intended but
unexpected or maybe intended and
expected consequences of what we believe
is the forthcoming supreme court ruling
overturning roe v wade and we said well
they'll probably try coming for gay
marriage they'll probably try coming for
co-payment fee contraceptives they're
going to try these things and we've
since heard from the texas governor of
uh um the republican governor of texas
greg abbott that they want to come for
the supreme court decision that says the
children of undocumented immigrants have
to be allowed to go to public school
they want to end that
and we've heard all these different
things i have a very very dangerous uh
example of this for you today
anti-choice activist abby johnson
appeared with radical right conspiracy
theorist stu peters
and previewed the idea of executions of
abortion providers right
if you believe in the death penalty
and you believe abortion is murder
and you believe that it is the abortion
provider that is committing the murder
then it would almost logically follow
that you would say well we've got to put
the abortion providers to death now as a
reminder stu peters the guy on the left
of your screen if you're watching today
he is the same guy who once had either
the flu or covet
and he claimed
that he was targeted by a bio weapon
because he's against vaccines
instead of just being like well actually
the simplest thing is i got the thing
i'm not vaccinated against that actually
makes a lot more sense okay so it's stu
peters interviewing abby johnson
when they say this stuff we should be
listening to them okay so abortion is
illegal in my state
and that's great when roe is overturned
but what does that actually mean
it means that it's murder it's murder
and we need a murderer then it needs to
be treated like murphy that's right and
we need a governor with the balls to
stand up and say that
i will bulldoze every single planned
parenthood facility in my state i will
bulldoze any facility that facilitates
this murder of unborn babies
okay now
this is not
this is not merely something that they
say
there have been
dozens or hundreds
of acts of vandalism violence and terror
at family planning clinics across the
country
and abortion doctors have also been
murdered
okay so these are not idle threats and
listen to the words that they're using
pre-born real living people
i will make it a criminal offense to
fund anybody that does this and if you f
if you found out funding murder or
carrying out murder you will be executed
period
that's what needs to happen
they need to be indicted and they need
to be tried and they need to be executed
now before we go on to the civil war
part that they talk about
um
there are some on the radical
anti-choice right
who say
try and execute
the abortion providers
there are others who go further and say
execute the mother as well because
ultimately she's consenting to the
procedure
that's that's a controversial position
even among the rights some on the right
say no the women are the victims so you
don't go after them and there's
it's a fraught question because
politically
there are problems on both sides of that
it's a crazy conversation i'm acting
like it's a rational conversation it's
not but certainly execute the abortion
doctors they mostly feel pretty good
about let's move on to the next section
now it's a war over
uh
slavery right why
because there was a group of people
who were seen and treated as sub-human
and right now
in our country
there is a group of people who are seen
and treated as subhuman now understand
she's talking about fetuses as a group
of people
that is part of how they identify with
this issue
i mean we are in our society at war
but maybe it means more than that
and maybe it should
if there was ever a time if there was
ever an issue
for us to
you know
actually go to war over wow you know if
there was ever a time when this becomes
illegal
and and if these clinics
try to remain open
and kill these babies
then maybe direct action needs to take
place
that's right
they're talking about a civil war
they're talking about violence by the
way at the bottom of the screen i don't
know if you can see this it says the
underbelly of the soros plan to kill
american babies so it's never a good
story on these right-wing channels
unless you can somehow involve george
soros in it as well
this is the right-wing wet dream
killing abortion providers legally
through the death penalty okay and
a civil war
this is they're not kidding and
hopefully this will never happen
but they're telling the truth that they
would like to see it happen and we know
there is willingness to do violence to
do uh to do murder
from the anti-choice right they've
killed people dr george tiller
family planning doctor we've talked
about it we covered it when it took
place i don't remember what year it was
was it
uh 2012. let me let me be clear on that
george tiller let me make sure i know
2009 sorry
2009 in wichita kansas george tiller was
shot dead by anti-choice activists
and uh i recently appeared on the the
daily wires michael knowles show again
to talk about uh this issue of abortion
and we're going to be publishing that
soon and you will see the way in the in
which these people talk about this issue
incites violence
it incites violence and uh
this issue is not going away anytime
soon